hey guys my name is just with dal it is
a twentieth of June today and we're here
with your top five of the week we only
have three shows this week so let's get
you covered up on all the good bits and
pieces from post III first up this week
we've got a video comparison showing us
what GTA 5 is going to look like on ps4
good looks real good digital foundry
knocked up a comparison video where you
can check out what the new version of
the game is gonna be delivering on on
top of the original it's just a trailer
comparison but the new shots look very
pretty and lend some weight to the
promises of more realistic looking water
ally Brent game world and more NPCs
wondering about for you to slaughter
mercilessly but please don't do that in
real life please thanks product
development head for Sony worldwide
studios America Scott Rudy talked about
micro transactions in sixty dollar games
and resolution related things this week
he said that the controversial inclusion
of microtransactions in games like Gran
Turismo 6 and drive club is done on a
case-by-case basis and there's no
particular policy attached to whether or
not the game should include the feature
he also commented on the display
resolutions that the ps4 is able to
output thing that they work hard to
deliver the best graphical fidelity they
can as for the 1080p business a lot of
you guys seem to agree with the tram man
in our gamespot comments who said 1080p
is walking pink thing want I bet a lot
of them can't tell the difference I find
the resolution in game similar to 3d in
movies looks interesting for a bit but
while you're playing you just forget
about it let me know if you agree or not
microsoft has made a comment about why
there III showing this year lacked any
information about PC games speaking to
polygon Phil Spencer said that III is
mainly a retail and console show and
they didn't feel that speaking about
Windows and gaming laws particularly
relevant nevertheless he said they're
committed to PC gaming and he thinks
that gaming on Windows is critical to
Microsoft success let me know if you
thought the PC showing should have been
more significant off you agree with Phil
now I empathize with the stupidness that
is the resolution debate but the founder
of oculus has said some fairly
interesting things seem to be directed
at the order 1886 deciding to run at 30
frames per second Palmer Luckey told PC
hardware community site latest tech tip
that virtual reality requires huge frame
rates to be successful and at 60 frames
per second is a baseline he followed
that up by saying he thinks Deb's opting
for 30 frames per second is not a smart
or a good artistic decision and rather
sees it as a failure this is in contrast
to the auto dev ready at dawn who stated
last month that they chose to run at 30
frames per second by design aiming for a
more filmic looks to complement the
game's art style
Plus that we finally got a look at some
of the gameplay of blood-borne that's
the ps4 exclusive coming from the
masterminds behind demon and dark souls
it looks very Souls II which you'd
expect from from software but it also
has more of a cool horror vibe with some
gruesome looking these days that you
really just want to take a sword into
the game is scheduled to launch in 2015
and it's been produced in conjunction
with Sony Japan studio you can check out
the complete 92nd gorefest on games but
now let me know if you're keen for this
one and what you hope it's going to
deliver on as well as what your favorite
[ __ ] three stories have been this week
on site cam exposes a load of super
secret III goodness on reality check the
just digs into which xbox one games are
worth buying that consults wharf and
check out our super speedy 30 in 3 2014
games in 30 seconds video that is it for
our super short week of GS news but next
week we'll be back without regular five
shows to make sure you don't miss a
thing that happens in gaming till then
be sure to have a great weekend